spoiler alert lorry Hernandez and Val
Chmerkovskiy went season 23 of Dancing
with the Stars my goal is just to
inspire others as I go on with my
journey
the winners and new champions of Dancing
with the Stars har Laurie and vow for
the first time ever it came down to
three athletes remaining in Tuesday's
finale
but 16 year old Olympic gold medalist
Lori and her pro partner Val
took home the coveted mirror ball trophy
let me present the trophy to the new
champions the pair have been
frontrunners since the very beginning
receiving the first perfect ten of the
season you are and not to mention have
overcome a lot throughout the season
including the death of Lori's
grandmother I'm very very proud of you
momenta the dynamic duo made it into the
finales and it was well deserved
they served up in awe inspiring
freestyle nailed their Paso Doble and
their 24-hour fusion of the Argentine
tango foxtrot sealed the deal on tuesday
ET spoke with a pair after their big win
I'm just so excited that I was able to
have this opportunity and even beyond
the show cuz I feel like I really spread
it as a person and I've surrounded
myself with there's so many amazing
people that I can now call families you
got some medals you got some trophies
where's the Mirrorball gonna go in
conjunction with all everything else you
got um some place probably like in the
middle my house as long as my mom's okay
with it compare this moment Mirrorball
trophy here was Val it's a break to
bring it home the goal is the same I
mean it's like once you figure out that
you you know won something for you it's
like a wave hits you it's not about the
toast tomorrow it's about the friendship
you know and you'll be on the tour
together we still get today yes I still
get to dance and this show also made me
realize how much I love dancing so I'm
glad I get to do more of it
you